Before we do some exercises,
I want you go back to x code and
open up the Maze project.
Once you have it open, I want you
to navigate to the Move.swift file.
It's located under Maze > Under The Hood
> Maze Moves > Move.swift.
This is where we describe the move
struct, but it's just a single file and
that seems a little confusing.
Since the robot is
moving more than once,
don't we need more than one move struct
or more than one Move.swift file?
The answer is no.
Think back to the analogies we
used like engine blue prints.
And the blue prints of a particular
component was defined only once.
But actual instances of the component
will physically exist in tens and
thousands of actual engines.
And that's what this file is.
It's like the blue print for
the move struct.
We create this single blueprint as we
can see here, in the Move.swift file,
and than we can create man instances
of the new struct in our application.
In programming lingo,
we'd call this blueprint a definition.
Or we would say that in the Move.swift
file, we define the move struct.